vous les attendez ces questions à 4/3 et
dans cette quatrième partie il n'y aura
que ça que jean luc lemoine et que ces
questions quelqu'un vous connaissez le
principe jean-marc ou pas vous
connaissez des missions non alors il ya
quelqu'un qui pose des questions enfin
des gens de ddt les emplois qu'elle sait
déjà les gens des téléspectateurs des
citoyens qui posent des questions et
vous y répondez oui exact on aux
téléspectateurs ça oui parce qu'ils
connaissent bien les dossiers les ont
une question parce qu'ils ont vu quelque
chose dans les quatre tiers non il ya
une dame qui avait une question à poser
c'est partie basse est partie
aujourd'hui bonjour je m'appelle thérèse
grâce à votre rubrique nous avons appris
que cyril hanouna trempé son zizi dans
des gobelets donc ma question est la
suivante at il d'autres qualités
ces gens qui vous connaissent bien ces
cons c'est une excellente question que
vous posez la chaire thérèse et oui
évidemment cyril a d'autres qualités
déjà c'est un peu tous en témoigner
c'est un homme consciencieux qui prépare
toujours ses émissions ces dossiers rien
n'est jamais improvisées et pour que
vous rendiez bien content je vais vous
montrer des images des coulisses juste
avant la prise d'antenne au moment des
tout derniers réglages
ce jour là nous avions commencé
l'émission avec un numéro de michael
jackson très au point
messieurs la concurrence prenez-en de la
graine vidéo d'emblée michael jackson
beat michael
je vous le dis je l'avais rencontrée en
fait dans l'ascenseur il a été l'autre
et messieurs gym vient bien faire voilà
il donc il est venu c'est ça commenté
cyrille le travail paye toujours
une autre séquence au hasard déjà vous
allez voir que si bertrand chamerois
elodie gossuin quitte l'émission l'année
prochaine
a priori ça ne sera pas pour participer
à ce virus mais plus étonnant dans
l'extrait c'est qu'à un moment vous
allez voir un homme entré dans le champ
qui a l'air très heureux on a
l'impression qu'il est à son mariage
ils regardent le ciel comme s'il était
touché par la grâce c'est pas faux
d'elle non c'est lui cyril ce qui va
surprendre notre invité du jour isabelle
boulay
m
g
alors s'énerve tout ce qu'il dit mais
par jeu m'a donné la foi jeu
vous connaissiez avant isabelle d'accord
ça va
vous avez vu pire c'est vrai ou si tu
avec isabelle morini bosc
et j'adore la chanson de ça vous avez un
bon flic et les invités ya quelques
semaines je vous ai montré comment cyril
et bertrand chamerois occuper leur temps
libre par les pubs
alors pour ceux qui l'auraient pas vu
c'est un beau père jean-marc un petit
rappel aux noms aussi accès sont assis
vous noterez au passage la grande
utilité de mokhtar dans ce genre de
situation
on
je pars pas
non moi c'est clair un cocktail des
motards est là pour défendre cyril le
patron tout le monde peut faire péter
sagan
il ne bouge ça c'était avant
c'est bien vrai maintenant je vous
rassure c'est fini la bagarre je finis
les deux ont grandi
oui relation évolue et oui oui un peu
bizarrement je dois dire quoi touche au
cul
tout ce qu est ce que tu de ce quick est
tout ce qu de ce qu'est ce qu'une qui
tous ceux qui l'adorent bis et le savez
tous que tu je me demande si je préfère
bas quand vous le papier non mais on
respecte votre couple mais il ya des
endroits pour ça on a réussi mais
attendez vous a rien fait bah non
alors ok alors regardé pendant que les
chroniqueurs se prépare la parade
nuptiale qui se joue dans leur dos moi
je m'envoie l'année ne devrait pas
prolonger un moment là nue
là je suis sur l'année l'astuce ont
aussi la nuit oui
ce public et expliquer les bonbons à la
vie ou ou à face à autre chose à à
s'user mois bertrand s'est pas sentie
baisser baisser des extrêmes quand même
entre vous deux mais bon y'a pas que
annie et à nu qui danse il ya aussi
gilles verdez qui dans sa f10 sortent un
peu de nous vous avez trouvé ça va
garder un peu de mystère
non j'ai verdad danse et ça c'est pour
le plus grand bonheur des vieux du
muppet juste en face est-ce qu'on veut
pas dire qu'on a un peu on sème on est
des frérots on s'entraide
c'est méchant pour gilles et qui fait ce
qu'il peut avec ce qu'il a 1
donc pour vous connaissez principe quand
on est méchant angie qu'est ce qu'on
fait bah pour consoler je passe des
images de son idole
oui de sa constellation bretonne
mesdames et messieurs un peu de glamour
avec enora malagré sexy nahdhaouis
c'est nora merci de quitter le plateau
vous êtes le maillon faible au revoir et
voici mettre autre chose et je suis dit
luc
je suis dit c'est ça alors ça et je sais
ça c'est bien sûr vous retrouver tous
les sucres dans le respect de toutes les
grilles du sud bon ça fait du bien un
peu de fraîcheur alors la semaine
dernière nous recevions qui nicolas
batum 1 et nous allons profiter avec
cyril et gilles pour le défier au basket
le tout sous le regard admirateur de nos
camarades restés en plateau des 400 t il
à rester et jean luc et jean luc djabla
c'est là jean gabaret quantité de plus
c'est joe dassin joda palais alors non
je sais pas ce qu'il a avec gilles et
moi c'est pour jean-michel mais a priori
on ne sera pas invité à son anniversaire
mais bon on va être sport on va voir si
le pronostic de jean-michel était le bon
merci on avait l'impression trompeuse
laissée jouer ça
j'ai l'abruti mais honnêtement vous
trouvez ça gentiment
non c'est pas gentil à prix trop bas
tant pis pour toi à chaque fois tu
demandes d'autres ménages est bas
calculs länder série l'a reproché à jean
michel2 travailler son émission de radio
pour dans la télé bah c'est faux c'est
pire
pendant que cyril parle jean michel est
concentré sur autre chose tout de suite
pendant la fashion week end vous allez
voir les nouvelles aventures de nos
premiers pas sur le reste ou non la
cachaine commun j'aimais mon chum c'est
à dire être autant qu'il pense
vous devez être au top on va
mais qui perché quand il va recevoir un
coup de fil sauvé les falaises d'étretat
par son chewing-gum écrasé n'importe
quoi je pense que dans un yaourt nature
et voit le taj mahal mais bon ce qui me
choque le plus ce que je trouve
inadmissible c'est qu'ils ne vous écoute
pas en permanence six mois parce que
c'était pendant l'émission
montréjeau ça fait vous inquiétez pas
j'emmagasine écoute le ce que c'est
dommage mais il pourrait tellement
s'instruire ou rire il faut le savoir
même pendant les pubs s'il continue les
blagues pour le plus grand bonheur de
thierry moreau
c'est très
m
et à pétanque ont skié mais niveau qui
annonçait lui aussi parce que c'est un
patron plus ou moins qu il a persisté
jean michel vous n'aurez pas de coups de
fils aux week-ends
tu peux vous donner très bon on va vous
donner vous appellerai directement la
rédaction de télé 7 jours on vous le
savez maintenant thierry se trouve plus
drôle que si rire de ça c'est normal ça
c'est vrai mais ceci étant je dois
reconnaître qu'il maîtrise une chose
incroyable
la vanne invisible à laisser ça à laval
un visible souci car oui il ya pire
qu'une mauvaise vanne ya la vanne dont
tout le monde se fout on fait semblant
de ne pas entendre la preuve avec cette
blague ou thd est délicieuse qui
concernait la réalisatrice de sous les
jupes des filles audrey dana
tu crois qu'un audrey dana l'avenir avec
sa tribu
le contre d'autres 16 tu crois qu audrey
dana en irak cette tribune vous poser sa
tombe s'il ne peut pas découpler je veux
pas entendre ce courant tandis que si
c'est pas ils insistent pourtant mais
bon par fidélité pour le patron jean
michel refuse de rire à d'autres blagues
que celle de cyril à ercis jean-michel
car si c'est une langue de [ __ ] avec
toutes les autres chroniqueurs
quand on a en face de celui qui lui fait
des chèques alors là il y avait une
fédération française des faux culs c'est
lui la mascotte en plus jeunes donc
faisons tout de suite un point sur le
classement des plus grands flatteur de
cyril avec un nouveau numéro du palmah
les joies et j'adore j'adore et perd
encore une place et c'est mérité car il
ne dit plus tôt vient de série dans les
médias depuis plus de quatre mois
valérie bénaïm série c'est un type
incroyable c'est un bac leur incroyable
il a compris que dans tokyo il ya donc
il ya chaud
elle perd une place cette semaine mais
sa comparaison avec bébel lui permet
quand même de rester dans le trio de
tête
enora malagré oui comme ça c'est certain
animé par un homme peut compter sur tout
savez on a longtemps ce pour moi c'est
le jean paul belmondo de la télé on a
souvent dit que c'était le guignolo est
en fait c'est le magnifique
sachez le
hors antenne il lèche tellement le q26
reid qu'il a maintenant un cheveu sur la
langue
il mérite bien sa première place et jean
michel maire bonne idée
c'est le bonheur des fans
moi je te dis tout ça sans prompteur
si vous voulez gagner un magnifique
téléviseur offertes par notre chance à
tous et vous à ok tu as de la chance tu
crois pas
un troisième à quatrième
m
papon c'est le patron c'est très
difficile à déloger les derniers soldats
bonjour je m'appelle françoise grâce à
votre émission j'ai découvert
l'humoriste gilles verdez et in en
tournée actuellement et est ce qu'un
jour il pourra nous faire entendre sa
vraie voix
oh